Ich frage dir wahrscheinlich, wer ist dieser unfassbar akkulative Mann, neben Stefan Tietze, das bin ich, was ich schon mal am Weltentübte und heute zu Gast Stefan Tietze. Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Ne, das müsst ihr ja nicht im Intro sagen, das würden wir dann jetzt machen. Das können wir schon noch selber machen, das Intro soll schon noch handgemacht sein, denn hier kommt es. Herzlich willkommen bei Das Podcast UFO mit Titz, wie heißt er, Titzinger, Titzel, Titzkopf, Stefan, der Stefan. Herzlich, bis nächste Woche. Nein, Stefan. Herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO, heute im Grobm Grobmerz. In den Iden des März, im Anfang des März. Männer. Mit Stefan, schön, dass ihr da seid, und natürlich als Dritter am Tisch. Frederico Pizzolini ist mit am Start. Si, claro, ist dabei und hat uns mit seinen herrlichen mediterranen Klingen ein bisschen in die Folge geführt. Ich tanze zu aggressiv, hat man mir mal gesagt. Ich habe, glaube ich, auch jetzt, das war fast schon Kampfsport. Du tanzt zu aggressiv? Ich tanze zu aggressiv, zu ruckartig, also zu energetisch. Aber da möchte ich mal jetzt die Leute, möchte ich dich angreifen, möchte ich dich gerne in Schutz nehmen, weil was sind das für Leute, die einem sagen, wie man tanzt?
Ich glaube, die waren um ihre Sicherheit bemüht, also wirklich aktive Sicherheit, weil ich bin jemand, ich tanze aus dem Oberkörper raus, die meine machen gar nichts. Ich glaube, würdest du mich... Das Gegenteil von einem Riverdance-Menschen. Genau, würdest du meinen Oberkörper auf dem Riverdance-Unterkörper photoshoppen, meine Herren, würde ja viel zu viel passieren. Ich glaube, wenn du so einen Glastisch hättest und ich würde auf dem Glastisch tanzen und jemand schaut von unten und sieht nur die Füße, der würde nicht denken, dass ich tanze. Der würde denken, was dreht sich der Mann so langsam im Kreis. Weil ich tanze primär aus dem Oberkörper und natürlich auch viel mit den Armen, viel mit den Fäusten. Und dann, also es ist fast, könnte fast wie ein Überlebenskampf aussehen, wenn man nicht wüsste, dass Musik läuft.
Hilft dir doch nicht, dass du deine Augenbrauen zusammenkneifst, weil die Musik auch nervt, die laute Musik und es auch mehr so ein, oh, nicht hier raus, also Leute, die so in ganz kaltes Wasser gehen, so Wim Hof mässig, die dann so, sich so Mut zu reden, um aus der Situation bald rauszukommen, aber irgendwie gezwungen sind, in der Situation zu sein. So bist du beim Tanzen.
Ja, so bin ich. Es ist wie ein Eisbad gesteckt und du bist dann da, versuchst zu überleben. Ja, und wenn meine Hände nicht wild um mich schlagen, halte ich mir die Ohren zu, weil die Musik einfach saulaut ist, muss man auch einfach mal sagen. Angestrengter Blick, Ohren zugepresst, bist du einer... Aber tanzt, aber weil du es gelernt hast. Weil so bin ich nämlich auch, ich bin auf Tanzflächen, glaube ich, irgendwann entgleist mir mein Gesicht und mein Gesicht verrät, ich bin ein sehr offen lesbarer Mensch, ich bin ein offenes Buch.
Und ich kann nicht gut verschleiern, wenn ich mir gerade unwohl fühle, mich auch unwohl fühle in der Situation.
So und dann auf der Tanzfläche, glaube ich, ab Minute zwölf im Club sagt mein Gesicht, ich will ja eigentlich nicht sein, aber mein Körper tanzt, weil es gelernt ist und weil man ja auch dazugehören will. Also das, glaube ich, ist von außen betrachtet immer ein merkwürdiger, was ist mit dem grossen Mann da hinten, geht es ihm gut. Und das sehen halt auch alle, weil alle im Raum deinen Kopf gut sehen können, deswegen du bist wie so eine Art, wir treffen uns später am Stefan, sagt man ja häufig. Genau, am Stefan, am Sankt Stefan.
Egal was passiert,
ich habe meine Jacke da beim Großen aufgehängt,
deswegen trifft man sich da. Aber hast du dir schon mal die Ohren
zugehalten, indem du die Zeigefinger
in dein Gehörgang
es gibt ja zwei Arten von sich
die Ohren zu halten, die flache Hand auf die
Ohrmuschel pressen und dann
den Finger reinbohren,
was ich glaube ich nur in Filmen
gesehen habe. Ich habe noch nie einen Menschen gesehen,
der sich so die Ohren zuhält. Ich kenne es nur aus Comics, aus so Duck-Tales-artigen, so. Haben die Hände? Nein, aber so diese Art von Comics, die stecken sich immer die Finger ganz ins Ohr. Ja, ganz, also wie laut muss es sein, dass man dazu bereit ist? Das ist wahrscheinlich die letzte Sache. Naja, ich verstehe auch nicht, bei Konzerten gibt es Leute mit Ohrenschonern, verstehe ich das nicht so richtig, weil ihr geht doch dahin, habt doch viel Geld bezahlt, um jetzt die Musik zu hören. Ja, eigentlich bräuchte man diese Trichter, diese Ohrtrichter, dass man sagt, ich habe hier gezahlt, das spielt Stacey Melua, ich will hier so viel Klang einsaugen, wie es nur geht, so an die Box mit dem Trichter. Ist Stacey Melua die ältere oder die jüngere Schwester von Katie Melua? Das ist die Nichte, die aber auch sehr guten, wieder sehr erfrischenden Nineties-Nostalgie-Rap macht. Also wieder wie die Neunziger, wie die Beastie Boys so ein bisschen in die Richtung mit Jump Around und Energie und so. Und jetzt ist sie natürlich mit ihrer Tante, Katie Melua, ist es eher eine Bürde oder eher eine Erleichter? Nein, also natürlich die Connections zu den Plattenlabeln haben ihr natürlich auch am Anfang geholfen, aber klar muss man sich mit dem Namen Melua auch abgrenzen, das ist klar. Also viele erwarten da eher ihre Tante, wenn sie auf Konzerte gehen, damit hat sie schwer zu kämpfen, wäre es richtig. Deswegen ist sie auch unterwegs mit ihrem Künstlernamen Stacy mit einer Acht drin. Also State, eigentlich, wenn man es ganz genau aussprechen würde, würde man Stacy aussprechen. Aber sie heißt Stacy, aber halt S-T-Acht-Y. Das wäre übrigens Stacy, aber gut. Das C ist völlig abhandengekommen. Du könntest auch ST und dann 8-0. Stati. Ihr erstes Album I'm Not Katie ist direkt auf Platz drei in den US-amerikanischen Charts eingestiegen. Genau, auch hier I'm Not K8Y Das zieht sich durch. Katie, da passt es besser. Passt richtig gut. Also das ist so ein bisschen ihr Steckenpferd und das macht sie toll. Falls ihr euch fragt, wer diese helle Stimme ist eigentlich, die uns hier folgt, das ist Stefan. Du bist ja sonst eigentlich eher im Hintergrund beim Podcast. Helle Stimme? Ja, eher helle Stimme. Eher helle Stimme. Nee, findest du nicht? Was, was, was? Ich habe doch eher ein dunkler, tiefer. Nein, helle, grelle, ein gellender Klang. Eine bedrohliche Stimme habe ich doch. Es ist auch oft so, dass du was sagst und die Leute sagen, scheiße, ist das der Feueralarm, was ist hier los? Also du hast schon was Geräuschiges irgendwie. Okay, und warum sollten uns die Leute fragen, wer ich bin? Du bist ja sonst eher im Hintergrund aktiv im Podcast-Ufo, du machst ja
viel, du kümmerst dich um die Räumlichkeiten, du kümmerst dich um die Social-Media-Auftritt.
Und heute bist du mal vorm Mikrofon. Herzlich willkommen. Ja, hallo, genau. Ja, Florian hat
mich ja da mal eh vor das Mikro gezerrt, um zu erklären, dass wir jetzt auch ein bisschen eine andere Raumsituation haben.
Vielleicht hört ihr es schon und vielleicht ist es der Grund, warum ihr im Bus euch die Ohren zudrückt und die Augenbrauen zu einem genervten Augenabenteuer bringt, weil es ein bisschen Halt. Es halt noch ein bisschen, aber es wird besser. Wir sind in neue Räumlichkeiten gezogen, wo wir immer aufnehmen und unser eigenes Studio aufbauen können. Was langfristig, langfristig, liebe Leute, das ist auch eine Investition. Diese Folge ist eine Investition. Ihr hört diese Folge, klingt scheußlich, aber in der Zukunft ist diese Folge eine Investition in eine ganzheitlich bessere Aufnahmequalität. Da müsst ihr erstmal kurz durch. Ja, da müsst ihr jetzt durch, so sieben, acht Folgen oder so müsst müsst ihr jetzt mal durchkneifen, könnt ihr auch durchskippen. Es war mal besser. Es war mal besser. Es war mal viel besser. Es war mal viel besser. Wir waren bei einem richtig professionellen Aufnahmestudio, dann waren wir lange bei uns zu Hause auch, die Skype-Phase, an die wir glaube ich nicht mehr denken müssen. Ne, wir haben auch gesagt, wir wollen darüber nicht reden. Ich verstehe nicht, warum wir das wieder... Ne, sorry, und deswegen... Es ist halt unschön. Ne, wir sind jetzt auf der Brücke, wir haben die Brücke, wir haben jetzt unseren eigenen Ort, wo wir uns austoben können und ja, also wir machen hier viel Debugging und Podcasting, ist so ein bisschen unser Motto. Debugging, Podcasting und ein bisschen Grafikdesign auch. Grafikdesign gehört. Es ist halt wirklich einfach eine Büroetage, wo wir ein paar Kollegen schon kennengelernt haben gerade und man ist sofort in einer Stromberg-Episode. Also man muss einfach mal so sagen, man ist sofort bei Herrn Döbel, bei Herrn Nübel. Der Herr Ulrich hat angerufen und meinte, ich soll dir nochmal den Vertrag folgen. Legen Sie es mir ins Büro. Legen Sie es mir ins Büro, links ist mir ins Fach. Ja, auf Wiedervorlage. Gerade schon gab es ein paar kleine Problemchen schon, die aufgetaucht sind und überwunden wurden, also so kleine Schlüsselproblemchen und so. Ich finde das ja super. Wir sind jetzt einfach ein Stück weit erwachsen geworden. Ich habe das mit der Frau Schmidt-Waller abgesprochen und das klang anders, als sie es gesagt hat. Und jetzt müssen wir noch... Ach nee, ich habe aber mit dem Herrn Kitsch telefoniert und der wollte mir eigentlich die Schlüssel noch rauslegen. Ach so, weil Herr Reisinger meinte, dass der Herr Kitsch eigentlich noch bis zum Dritten im Urlaub ist. Deswegen war ich jetzt verwirrt, weil ich dachte, der Anruf kommt aus seinem Büro, nicht von ihm direkt.
Und was ist mit dem Übergabeprotokoll, das habe ich auch noch nicht ganz verstanden.
Das haben wir jetzt nicht da, da waren wir jetzt nicht darauf vorbereitet. Wir dürfen das hier einfach nur um zehn kommen.
Wir kürzen das hier ab, wir machen das so, ist kein Problem, wir machen das einfach morgen.
Ja, aber das können wir nicht einfach so abkürzen, ich habe doch jetzt das Formular hier liegen, was mache ich denn damit, wer unterschreibt das denn dann jetzt?
Ich rufe den Herrn Mitsch kurz auf den kurzen Dienstwerk an.
Der Herr Mitsch ist doch gerade auf einer Fortbildung. Der kommt heute erst um 18 Uhr zurück, da müssen Sie warten. Ja, okay. Dann standen wir 19 Stunden am Empfang. Es ist jetzt gerade minus ein Uhr. Ich müsste jetzt 19 Stunden warten. Ja, aber das ist ja auch nicht... Ja, dann setzen Sie sich da hin, können sich ein Glas Wasser nehmen, dann müssen Sie halt 19 Stunden warten. Ja, wenn das mit mir niemand abspricht. Was soll ich noch machen? Das kann aber auch nicht sein. Das habe ich aber auch schon mal gesagt. Da müssen wir ein bisschen besser uns organisieren hier. Nee, ich finde es gut. Es läuft alles super, man ist aber sofort in so einer Stromwerk-Episode drin. Und ja, also man ist automatisch erwachsener geworden und wieder im Jahre 2007. Genau, ja. Mit dieser Ambivalenz kommt mein Gehirn gerade noch nicht so richtig klar. Ja, und wir bewegen uns ja immer in so einer Welt zwischen Fiktion und Realität. Und manchmal hat man so Momente, wo man merkt, die sind gar nicht so weit voneinander entfernt. Die sprechen wirklich so wie in diesen Büroserien. Das ist alles auch viel echt. Also ich glaube, wenn wir dann mal ins Mittelalter gehen oder so und merken, dass die wirklich so Shakespeare-mässig sprechen und denken sich, ja, sprecht wirklich so, what dost thou program be to my demise? Ach so, hello guys, sorry. Hello guys, das ist Stefan Flonin von Germany, actually. We were wondering if you could speak less cringy. Genau, ich glaube, es ist am Ende, am Ende ist die Realität mehr als die Fiktion, als wir das wollen. Also willst du gerade sagen, life imitates art, imitates life. Ja, genau das würde ich sagen. Ist die Frage, ne, also ich unterstelle jetzt mal Ralf Hussmann, dass er jetzt nicht so lange in der Versicherung gearbeitet hat, aber wahrscheinlich hat er sich mal irgendwo dahingesetzt für ein paar Monate und hat ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, die passiert sind. Ja, ich glaube, er hat sich ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben und ein paar britische Serien geschaut. Und dann, glaube ich, kommt man da auch ein paar Ideen, wie man das umsetzen kann. Aber von daher schon relativ realitätsnah getroffen. Und das ist der bissige Podcast, den ihr, deswegen ihr uns einschaltet. Der Podcast mit Biss. Die nach oben treten, weil unten nichts mehr ist. Ja, wir haben einige viele Mails auch bekommen zum Thema Lokalstolz, weil du ja gesagt hast, das Kamener Kreuz, ja, das grösste Autobahnkreuz der Welt. Ich habe gesagt, Lokalpatriotismus abschaffen, indem wir Städte abschaffen. Ja, aber hast dann doch nochmal zurückgerudert und deinen Kamener Stolz dann nochmal deine Brust gereckt. Und wir haben viele tolle Beispiele bekommen, auf die wir gerade nicht zugreifen können, weil wir keinen Zugang zum WLAN haben. Genau, wir haben noch ein Problem, wir haben noch ein bisschen infrastrukturelle Probleme, aber das kriegen wir alles. Aber wir haben auf jeden Fall viele tolle Lokalkohlerite bekommen, die Fachhandwerksstadt mit Pfiff, weil es den Pfeifferturm gibt, also viele tolle Claims von vielen kleinen Städten, die sich richtig Mühe geben, cool zu wirken, wo man exakt so ist wie jede andere Stadt in Deutschland auch.
Was ich auch bewundernswert finde, was bei Reddit ab und zu mal auftaucht auf der Frontpage, ist irgendwo in Baden-Württemberg oder so gibt es diesen Turm, wo die Thyssenkrupp-Aufzüge getestet werden. Und das ist einfach ein sehr schöner, sehr schmaler Turm.
Die einzige Funktion ist, da werden Aufzüge getestet.
Und die Stadt Brunsweiler freut sich auch sehr darüber, dass sie diesen Aufzugturm haben. Und das ist deren ganze Identität. Und dann denke ich mir, aber jetzt wird es mal bis albern, weil jetzt konzentriert ihr eure ganze Identität auf so eine unglaublich spezielle Art. Das ist da, wo der Aufzugturm ist. Das ist dein, sorry, aber Kramer hat zumindest noch das grösste Autobahnkreuz. Ich sage jetzt auch nicht, dass es das beste ist, aber da schwingt was mit. Da schwingt mit, ah, okay, wir sind irgendwo in einer Metropolregion. Da schwingt mit, ah, okay, vielleicht gibt es da nicht so viel Kultur, ist eher Arbeiterstadt. So was schwingt da mit. Aber wir sind die Stadt mit dem Aufzugturm, ja, okay, jetzt erzähl mir, wie deine Kindheit war. Aber wie ist denn der Claim? Mit Brunsweiler kommen sie hoch hinaus, rauf, rauf, rauf, immer schön den Turm rauf. Je nach Ausgang des Testes kommen sie mit uns hoch hinaus oder stürzen tief ab. Aber keine schlechte Investition. Ich glaube, Aufzüge werden die Menschen nimmer brauchen. Ich habe mich gefragt, warum man die nach unten bohrt. Ach so, du machst ein Tiefhaus statt einem Hochhaus, meinst du, oder wie? Also ich verstehe es für die Skyline von Bunsbü-Vü-Li, dass man nach oben baut. Vielleicht weil unten ja schon Erde ist. Da ist schon was. Da ist schon was. Da muss nichts weg. Wohingegen in der Luft, da ist ja noch nichts. Aber jetzt meine Frage, und darauf läuft alles in Haus, ist es einfacher, Dinge wegzunehmen oder Dinge aufzubauen? Ja. Nee. Aber hat ein Hochhaus auch... Das ist eine erste Frage. Ist es nicht einfacher, ein Loch in die Tiefe zu bohren, als magically neue Materialien in die Luft zu errichten? Nur weil du das Wort magically jetzt hinzufügst und damit deine Frage sehr suggestiv machst. Weil die Antwort ist ja offensichtlich, dass es leichter ist, in die Höhe zu bauen. Aber hat ein Hochhaus, hat dann auch mehrere Untergeschosse? Also ein normales Haus hat zwei Stöcke und ein Kellergeschoss, also zwei zu eins. Hat jetzt so ein hundert Stockwerke hoch aus dann auch fünfzig Untergeschossstöcke? Klar, er muss sich umkippt. Eigentlich schon, oder hat es dann auch nur ein Untergeschoss? Oder wie läuft das? Wenn überhaupt, wenn überhaupt. Da gibt es doch bestimmt so einen Schlüssel, dass du sagst, alle acht Stockwerke nach oben ist ein Stockwerk nach unten oder sowas in der Richtung. Ja, aber das geht ja in New York ja gar nicht. Da sind ja die höchsten, teilweise manche der höchsten Häuser der Welt und unten drunter ist ja die U-Bahn. Jetzt haben die so 150 Stöcke oder so und dann, ja, U-Bahn, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert. Die werden ja immer schmaler, die Hochhäuser. Da habe ich jetzt viele Videos gesehen und fand ich sehr spannend, weil der Trend ist jetzt ganz hohen, schmalen Gebäuden, die dann so am Central Park gebaut werden, die komplett leer stehen, weil einfach ganz reiche Menschen das als Investition nehmen. Und es ist für die super, es ist für die die beste Investition, diese Wohnung zu kaufen, nichts damit zu machen, haben keine Arbeit damit, nichts, lassen die einfach leer stehen und verkaufen die für mehr Geld weiter. Das heißt, sie werden gar nicht so gebaut, damit da Leute drin wohnen können, sondern einfach nur damit das gut aussieht und gut verkaufbar ist. Das heißt, du könntest im Grunde das Brunswödler-Modell dann genau die richtige Richtung. Du hast einen ganz dünnen Turm mit ganz vielen Aufzügen und dann verkaufst du diese ganzen Stockwerke, weil niemand muss da drin wohnen. Ja, aber das Problem, genau, also du überspringst quasi diesen Teil, wo man Scheinwohnungen errichtet, in denen man wohnt, Augenzwinker, Augenzwinker, und man behauptet einfach so, da könnte man ja theoretisch irgendwann mal ein schönes geräumliches Wohnzimmer einbauen auf dem achten Etage des Aufzugturms. Wir testen aber Aufzüge. Aber wie ist denn der Maklertermin, wenn du nur als Investor kommst und der Makler sagt, ja, hier könnten sie dann zum Beispiel ihre Couch hinstellen und da könnte man Billardtisch hier aufbauen oder so. Und das einzige Problem ist natürlich, sie haben natürlich im Ost die Sonne, das heißt, morgens wird schon die Sonne ein bisschen hier reinknallen. Ich nehme es. Aber ansonsten sehr, sehr nette Nachbarn auch, also über ihnen ist leer, unter ihnen ist leer, also da können sie sich hier komplett austoben. Wie ist es, zwei Etagen drüber? Leer. Und zwei Etagen drunter? Da ist die U-Bahn, da können sie direkt einsteigen in die U-Bahn, also sie können direkt von ihrer Wohnung aus in die U-Bahn rutschen. Kann ich auch mal die Wohnung über mir zum Vergleich sehen einfach? Ja, können wir, können gerne mit dem Aufzug fahren. Okay. So, hier sind wir in der oberen Wohnung, Sie merken, sie sieht sehr ähnlich aus. Also hier könnten Sie gut ein Sofa hinstellen, da hinten könnte man die Ecke zum Beispiel für den Billardtisch oder so nutzen. Und ansonsten das einzige...
Wie ist hier mit den Leuten über mir?
Über ihnen ist komplett leer.
Einziges Problem ist leider, dass morgens richtig die Sonne reinknallt, weil wir sind hier 600 Meter in der Höhe.
Nichts versperrt mehr den Weg, sondern die Sonne...
Und trotzdem ist zwei Stöcke unter mir die U-Bahn.
Genau, also sie haben tatsächlich...
Hohe Decken unter mir offensichtlich.
Genau, also jeder Raum ist 300 Meter hoch, also sehr, sehr hohe Decken. Halt auch hier, ne? Halt, halt, halt! Ein Leuchtturm so ein bisschen. Aber wie gesagt, sie sind hier oben alleine mit der Sonne, also es gibt nichts, was sie aufhängt. Weil hier ein Mensch näher an der Sonne? Genau, sie haben hier auch 19 Stunden Tageslicht tatsächlich, weil wir sind hier so hoch, dass selbst wenn die Stadt unter ihnen die Sonne nicht mehr sieht, sie sehen die Sonne noch. Also sie können hier fast nicht schlafen, weil die Sonne hier rein knallt, als gäbe es kein Morgen. Und vielleicht bin ich mir ein, aber ich glaube, dass ich nicht mehr so viel Schwerkraft hier habe. Stimmt das? Genau, das ist tatsächlich so. Also wenn ich springe, kann ich höher springen. Richtig, genau. Deswegen sind die Wohnungen auch so hoch, damit sie einfach hier nicht sich den Döds anhauen, sondern einfach schön ein bisschen Puffer haben.
Sagt man hier in New York so, ne? Ja, ein bisschen schön, da kriegst du in New Yorker dann auch nicht raus aus mir. Und deswegen ist es also sehr angenehm hier oben zu leben, aber die Sonne knallt halt. Da kriegt man eh nicht raus. Das sag ich immer, du kriegst den New Yorker aus New York, aber du kriegst nicht New Yorker aus New Yorker raus. Ja, so ist es. Okay, und dass ja einfach eine Wolke in der Wohnung steht, weil offensichtlich die Außenwände mit kleineren Materialien, damit dieser schmale, hohe Turm gebaut werden kann. Bleibt das so? Ja, der Punkt, also ab dem achtzehnten Stock haben sie kein Wetter mehr. Also null bis siebzehn haben sie Wetter, Regen, ab dem achtzehnten Stock gibt es kein Wetter mehr, es ist immer nur die Sonne und sie. Dann würde ich gerne nochmal die Wohnung im achtzehnten Stock sehen. Können wir uns gerne mal anschauen, ja. So, das wäre dann die achtzehnte, also hier könnte man wunderbaren Sofa hinstellen zum Beispiel. Da hinten ganz tolle Ecke, irgendwie so ein bisschen für den Billardtisch oder sowas in der Richtung. Könnte man vielleicht so eine Art Hobby-Ecke machen. Und ansonsten, ja, das einzige Problem wäre halt, dass morgens die Sonne richtig reinknallt. Also weil, wie gesagt, sie sind hier so hoch in der Stratosphäre. Ist das normal, dass einem die Luft ein bisschen älger ist? Ja, die Luft ist ein bisschen dünn, ja, das stimmt. Hier müssen Sie sich auf dem Boden legen, sonst können Sie langfristig ersticken. Ja, das ist ein Problem. Aber ansonsten... Ich nehme die Wohnung. Sehr gut. Yes, die erste Wohnung, die ich verkauft habe. Alle anderen stehen leer. Hässlich, hässlich Gebäude. Aber eine schöne Rutsche. Ich glaube, ich will einfach eine Wohnung nur mit so einer Stange oder einer Rutsche, der Rest ist mir egal. Ja, gut, aber wenn du im 129. Stock bist, will ich mal sehen, wie du an der Eisenstange unten anfährst. Stefan, du, was ich schon für Rutschen gerutscht bin in meinem Leben, also sorry, den Kommentar kannst du dir sparen, weil ich glaube, ich war sehr viel im Alpamare zugange, eines der angesehensten Schwimmbäder Bayerns mit den grössten Rutschen, der Halsbrecherrutsche. Heisst die so? Nee, und die sehr steil ist aber. Wie kamen sie zu dem Namen? Ja, da sind 16 Kinder im Jahre 2011 leider ineinander. Also die wollten halt so wie so ein Bob, so ein ganz langer Elf-Kinder-Bob, gleichzeitig runterrutschen. Und dann ist leider vorne das erste Kind, da gibt es dann so diese eine Sache, wo von oben nochmal dieser Strahl kommt. Und leider war das Genick sehr schwach, weil das eigentlich erst ab 18 ist. Und das heißt, der Kopf des ersten Kindes ist nach hinten geschlagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du diese Aufhängungen kennst, die Newton-Kugeln, wo wenn von einer Seite ein Schlag kommt, geht es durch und dann einmal durch alle elf... Wir brauchen es nicht noch grafischer eigentlich. Okay, gut. Also nur, dass Sie wissen. Aber macht Spaß! Konkrete Frage habe ich, eine sehr konkrete Frage. Warum gibt es so viele Rutschen in Schuhläden? Kennst du das Phänomen? Ja, klar. Oblätter in München damals natürlich, da wolltest du immer hin. Ich glaube einfach, damit die Kinder dahin wollen. Ich wollte immer dahin als Kind. Schuhe wollte, gab es in Kamm, auch riesige Holzrutsche gehabt und ich habe immer nicht verstanden, also erst mal toll, man geht dann viel lieber in den Schulladen, Aber es könnten ja auch alle anderen übernehmen. Es könnten Kinderärzte übernehmen, das könnten Buchhandlungen übernehmen. Ich zähle alles auf, was mir jetzt einfällt. Es könnten Optiker übernehmen, das könnte Chibo übernehmen. Ja, gute Frage. Vielleicht werden die Eltern da viel Zeit brauchen, um die Schuhe anzuprobieren und den Kindern ist es langweilig und die rutschen hoch und runter. Ich weiß noch da... Du brauchst doch nicht mehr Zeit im Schuhladen als in anderen Läden. Hier mal an die Münchner, direkt am Stachus, da gibt es den Spielzeugladen Müller, glaube ich, heißt der oder sowas. Und da war früher doch auch diese Rutsche noch aktiv, die mittlerweile aber irgendwann, ich weiss noch, da wollte ich noch mal hin, als ich zwanzig war, studieren und wollte noch mal rutschen, dann war die aber gefüllt mit Bällen. Und dann habe ich gefragt, kann man hier nicht mehr rutschen, ich bin ja als Kind da mehr gerutscht, und ich saß, ne, aus Sicherheitsgründen wird jetzt aufgelöst. Weil da waren 16 männliche Kolonne aus Kindern, wo der erste... Ja, aber du hattest halt immer so ein Trottelkind, das versucht hat, die Rutsche nach oben zu klettern. Währenddessen sind immer weiter die Kinder runtergerutscht. Kennst du, wo du gerade mit der Geschichte angefangen hast, kennst du diese Paare, die sich dann so hinsetzen und einer sagt, weißt du, da am Stachus da war das doch. Und dann sagt dann die Freundin so, nee, das war nicht am Stachus. Und man weiss noch nicht, worum es geht, aber es ist schon dieser... Das ist auch völlig irrelevant, was das war. Aber es ist schon dieser kleine Mini-Streit ausgebrochen. Am Isator, Janett, du meinst am Isator, meinst du? Nee, ich meine da am Stachus, da war doch der Schula neben Dings. Nein, nein, du verwechselst jetzt mit dem Karstadt. Der Karstadt ist am Stachus, du meinst da unten in der Unterführung. Du redest vom Isator hinten bei der Voglerbar. Ja, bei der Voglerbar, genau, aber da war doch hier neben dem Dings, neben dem Dings, neben dem, ja, Sachstach. Du meinst, ah, jetzt was meinst du denn, da wo früher der Hertie war? Ne, der war doch am Stachus. Klar, aber stimmt, am Stachus. Ne, aber es ist ja die Frage zwischen Stachus. Meinst du jetzt vom Ostzugland? Aber doch neben dem Schulladen Wolter war doch Dings. Ne, du meinst jetzt ein Hugendubel, du bist jetzt ganz woanders. Ja, ich meine Hugendubel. Das ist der eine, den gibt es jetzt beim Hauptbahnhof und auch am Marienplatz.
Und währenddessen sitze ich einmal so vor Kopf und nehme so eine Knarre hoch, so eine Walter P99 und schiesse mir in die Fresse rein.
Und am Ende nach 40 Minuten lokale Diskussion einfach, da habe ich die Annette getroffen und die ist jetzt umgezogen.
Nein, die ist schwanger.
Es ist alles egal bis jetzt.
Die ist umgezogen, ja wohin denn? Schwanger umziehen, oder? Die Arme, eine Schwanger und dann umziehen, also das ist ja auch fehlverlangt. Also ich hoffe, die muss da nicht zu viel schleppen, ist ja auch nicht gut. Ach, der sich umgebracht hat. Wer sich neulich auch umgebracht hat, das war der Schwager von der Dings.
Du meinst die Bettina, das war der Onkel, nicht der Schwager.
Alles erzählen, außer das Wichtigste.
Wie nennt man so eine Form Gespräche? Ich weiß es nicht, ich glaube, ich habe jedes dieser Art Gespräche nach 30 Sekunden verlassen.
Wie denn? Wie zones du dann out?
Deswegen fange ich glaube ich an, so rumzufidgeten mit so Dingen, die dann da, so Besteck und so, oder Servietten. Schneide mit dem Messer in die Serviette rein oder falte die Serviette zu wunderschönen, akaischen Serviette. Serviette. Du hast jetzt dreimal Serviette gesagt. Serviette. Die Serviette. Im Ruhrgebiet sagt man die Serviette. Okay, gut, ich wollte es nur vor der Blamage bewahren. Ich dachte mir, zweimal lasse ich es durchgegeben, im dritten Mal muss ich es dann ansprechen. Na ja, Serviette, aber das ist doch albern. Ich bin echt neidisch auf so Videospielfiguren, die halt immer nur so sprechen können, ohne was zu sagen. Das würde ich gerne im Alltag können, dass du einfach sprichst, ja und die Annette auch nicht so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, spricht man nicht so.
Im Grunde spricht man so.
Mein Kopf macht das, auf dem Mund kommen dann grob Wörter und Sätze raus, die man kennt.
Ich glaube, du könntest ohne Nachteil so ein komplettes Gespräch in Fantasiesprache sprechen.
Es geht ja nur darum, dass man austauscht, man mag sich, man teilt Erfahrungen. Inhalte sind ja egal. Ich glaube, du könntest... So würde ich es am liebsten machen und dann kannst du halt einfach die Untertitel ausblenden. Soenden. Ich meine, wir alle haben bei Animal Crossing irgendwann die Untertitel nicht mehr gelesen, weil du einfach diese schon sprechen konntest. Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Stimmt eigentlich, die Untertitel hindern einen eigentlich daran, die Sprache wirklich zu lernen. Ich bin so sprachbegabt, dass ich sowohl Sims-sisch irgendwann fliessen konnte, weil irgendwann muss ich die Untertitel auch nicht mehr lesen.
Oder diese grünen, das wollte ich ja auch für den Alltag einführen, dass man, wenn man spricht zum Beispiel, und das wäre dann, wenn man angenommen so ein Gespräch, so eine Abends-Essen-Situation, dann kommt dieses, wo war denn der Schulladen-Gespräch, bei welchen Sims wäre über mir die ganze Zeit so ein rotes Minus, aber konstant.. Aber so das wieder so ein Sekundentakt. Irgendwann kommt ein zweites Minus. Und dann zweites rotes Minus. Wenn dann der Partner noch einschneide, nee, das war doch letztes Jahr. Boom, zweites, drittes rotes Minus, wenn es das gibt. Rotes Minus, rotes Minus. Und unten ist so meine Bereitschaft, den Abend zu verbringen. Geht so ganz schnell runter. Aber alle sehen es. Du musst es nicht aussprechen, aber alle sehen es. Das finde ich eigentlich auf eine Art beruhigend, weil die könnten ja dann merken,
ah okay, das, was wir gerade hier veranstalten, dieses Theater, lassen wir, wir beziehen jetzt den Stefan wieder ein.
Und reden wieder über Star Wars. Wie kriegen wir den rein?
Grünes Plus.
Ist es, was Chewbacca als Scherpe hat, ist es Kleidung, trägt Chewbacca Kleidung,
drei grüne Plus.
Ist er nackt? Weil manche Wookies auf Kaschuk haben wir gesehen, die haben Kleidung getragen, also ist Chewbacca jetzt immer nackt oder wie ist das, wie läuft das, ist das eine andere Kultur, sowas. Sowas, da hast du mich auch in der Hingebucht. Da wächst du mich zumindest auf. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da grüne Plusse um mich schieße mit grünen Plussen. Womit man bei dir auch immer grüne Plusse kriegen kann, ist natürlich das Thema Dinosaurier,
obwohl natürlich Stefan in letzter Zeit ein gebranntes Kind ein bisschen ist,
denn uns ereilen immer und immer wieder negative Nachrichten für unsere gefiederten Freunde
und deswegen möchte ich kurz unsere Rubrik aufmachen.
Ja, kann ich kurz eine Idee für das Intro raushauen in die Welt? Jetzt ist der beste Zeitpunkt dafür. Könnt ihr mal die... Entschuldigung, ich versuche hier gerade Softwareprogrammierung, ich programmiere gerade eine neue App. Genau, aber entschuldige, man hört wirklich alles hier bei uns nebenan, man hört wirklich alles komplett. Wir ziehen wieder aus, alles klar. Alles klar, okay, danke, Ein bisschen leiser. Das erwarte ich. Das hat doch... Oh, der Herr Grösel. Herr Grösel mit seinem Schwachsinn. Ach Gott, der mit seiner neuen App, oder? Als ob jetzt irgendwie jemand noch eine Dating-App bräuchte. Alle Ideen sind doch durch. So, alberner Witz. Wie lächerlich ist das denn? Hast du mal sein Büro gesehen, wie er es eingerichtet hat? Das ist lächerlich. So, alberner Witz. Zu gemüllt. Komplett zu gemüllt. Und er hat den Kühlschrank schon wieder offen gelassen. Das ist mir jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal abkommt. Der hat ja extra jetzt nochmal sein Schild dran gemacht, wo er seine Milch hat. Und trotzdem steht alles überall. Also leer. Milch leer. Und mit der Jurassic Park Musik? Die Idee wäre, kann das mal jemand in Moll umkommt. Ah ja, okay. Traurig. So, ich weiss dann nicht genau, wie es dann klingen wird, aber das finde ich sehr schön, wenn die Jurassic Park Musik auf Klavier oder was auch immer, nimmt ein Orchester, we don't give a fuck, aber auf Moll umkomponiert, das wäre dann jetzt unsere Rubrik. Abgesang auf Dinosauri, ja. Weil das alte Intro müssen wir nämlich austauschen, das kommt jetztauschen. Das geht nämlich so. Wir hören die Welt von Stino-News! Ja, also es tut mir leid, euch das mitteilen zu müssen, Leute, aber es wird hart. Es wird heute eine harte Woche. Es gibt aber einen kleinen Lichtblick, denn es kann sein, dass wir seit jeher einen Fehler gemacht haben. Dass wir seit jeher alle unsere Hoffnungen auf die Dinosaurier gesetzt haben und vielleicht das gar nicht das beste Tier war, auf das wir unsere Hoffnung setzen können. Denn diese Woche kam eine Schlagzeile raus, die ich dir jetzt zeigen möchte, Stefan, du kannst sie mal vorlesen, und zwar diese hier. Sensationsfund, I already love this, Urzeitkrokodil, Frass kompletten Dinosaurier. Genau, ein Urzeitkrokodil, Frass kompletten Dinosaurier. Im Magen des Fossils, einer neu bestimmten Krokodilart aus der Kreidezeit, haben Forscher ein halbverdautes Exemplar der Gattung Ornithopoda entdeckt. Der Fund liefert neue Aufschlüsse über die damalige Nahrungskette. Sprich, in der Nahrungskette stand über den Dinosauriern das Urzeitkrokodil. Und vielleicht sollten wir aus dem Fanklub der Dinosaurier aussteigen und einen neuen Urzeit-Krokodil-Fanclub gründen, weil ich glaube, der coolnes Richter hat gesprochen. Aber warum muss denn jetzt das Tier gewinnen, was wir schon kennen, was ich schon gesehen habe? Es ist ein Urzeit-Krokodil, ein Dinosaurier ist ein Urzeithuhn. Du kannst statt Dinosaurier noch Urzeithuhn sein. Hör auf Urzeithuhn zu sagen. Nee, du hörst jetzt auf Uhrzeithuhn zu sein. Aber Moment, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Krokodil, wie wir es so ein handelsübliches, so ein Kaufland-Krokodil und jetzt so diesem Urzeit-Krokodil? Anscheinend ist es riesengross. Schau dir diese Illustration an, die fucking Unwissenschaftlichkeit. Vielleicht ist noch der Lamo-Ass-Dino da, einfach nur unglaublich klein. Die Dinger waren riesengross. Verraten wir mal bitte eins. Verraten wir mal bitte eins. Warum? Achtung, in Australien haben Forschende der Universität of New England eine brisante Entdeckung veröffentlicht. Brisant. Im Magen eines versteinerten Krokodils aus der Kreidezeit wurden teilweise verdaute Überreste eines Dinosauriers entdeckt. Bei der Beute handelt es sich um ein ehemals rund 1,7 kg schweres Jungtier der Gattung Ornithopoda, etwa in der Größe eines Huhns. Also ein huhngrosses Urzeithuhn. Aber es ist ein Jungtier, der Ornithopoda, Ein Jungtier. Aber das ist ja die reißerichte Kack-Clickbait. Was ist denn mit National Geographic los? Leute, jetzt macht ihr da einen Riesenaufriss. Wie lange ist denn dieser Artikel, bitte? Bist du immer noch am Scrollen? Oh nein, ich hab den Artikel verloren. Naja, fuck. Ich hätte mich interessiert, wie gross das Urzeitkrokodil ist. Du hast natürlich recht, Krokodileile sind das nächste. Ja, aber wenn der Sensationsfund ist, dass ein 1,7 Mini-Kilo, ich kann ja ein 1,7 Huhn essen. Alles klar, nächste Woche bringe ich eins mit, dann machen wir die grosse Stefan-Tietze-Reiss-Maule-Auf-Show, wo Stefan-Tietze mal gucken soll, ob hinter den grossen Worten auch ein grosser Magen steckt. Ich bringe 1,7 grosses 1,7 Kilon mit, dass du komplett aufrissst. Und dann ein Sensationsfund? Aber nicht kauen. Wenn ich dann aus ewigem Grund auch versteinere, wo ich auch noch nicht genau weiss, wie das passiert, dann schreibt National Geographic über mich Sensationsfund, in einem Menschen wurde ein Ornithopod großes Lebewesen gefunden. Das ist doch nicht beeindruckend. Du kannst doch kein 1,7 Kiloes Huhn-Fressen. Ich will da nicht mit einem Bissen. Also würgen, reinwürgen. Nö, ich würde da ein bisschen die Messerangabe mit und dann wird ein bisschen rumgeschnitten. Ja, das geht aber nicht, weil damit man den als Dinosaurier erkennen kann, darf der den ja nicht gekaut haben. Weiß ich nicht. Den so Knochen, auf jedem Knochen ist so eine kleine Seriennummer. Oder nicht? Aber der hat dann den mit Knochen gefressen, oder was? Wahrscheinlich, weil eigentlich ist das Fleisch... Warum haben die Zähne, wenn die alles mit einem bisschen runterschlingen? Schling nicht so. Schling nicht so, Krokodil. Das ist dein Urteil. Ich sehe, du bist kein Fan des Urzeitkrokodils. Ich dachte, ich könnte deine prähistorische Liebe ein bisschen umschwenken heute. Mit dem Neuen prähistorisches Krokodil. Ich kenne Krokodile. Krokodile können auch so grosse Dinge essen. Ja, aber das ist ja ein riesengrosses Urzeit-Krokodil. Das ist halt... Warum? Aber ist es ja anscheinend nicht. Dann wäre der Sensationsfund ja nicht, wenn ein 1,7-Minididu, Mini-Urzeithuhn, gefressen wurde. Wäre das nicht ein Sensationsfund? Ja, aber manche Dinosaurier sind auch auf Äfferno gross wie ein grosser Komodowaran. Die sind nicht so weit weg von Tieren, die es gibt. Warum sind Tiere, die es gerade gibt, so viel fucking lamer? Verrat mir das mal. Das ist eine verdammt gute Frage. Ohne Scheiss, weil ich finde... Wo ist der Greif zum Beispiel? Fucking fliegender Löwe, Pegasus? Es kommt bald eine Serie heraus, der Greif. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob über dieses Und da hast du was mit dem Greifen zu tun? Oder mit diesen Jamax-Automaten, wo man sowas greifen kann. Es ist eine Serie über wie Jamax-Lobby Kinder verarscht. Ich finde es so spannend, weil natürlich gerade die Nuss auch entzaubert werden, die man darüber erfährt.
Aber je mehr man über etwas weiss, desto lamer wird es auch gerade irgendwie. Also Dinge, die man schon kennt, Tiere, die es gerade gibt, findet man ja generell eher ein bisschen langweilig. Stimmt nicht ganz, wenn man im Zoo ist und so, hier im Köln dazu gibt es Giraffen. Und wenn man da vorsteht, denkt man, holy shit, das ist ja wahnsinnig cool. Ja. Die sind so, man denkt wirklich, man ist kurz irgendwie auf Pandora gelandet und schaut sich jetzt die Navi an. So stehe ich vor. Weil die gross sind? Nicht nur, weil die gross sind, weil die so otherworldly aussehen. Die sind einfach so, auch dann diese Hörner, die sie haben, alles an denen sagt so Sci-Fi-Shit. Die sind doch recht nah an den Binosaurier dran, oder? Aber haben gar nichts damit zu tun, glaube ich. Aber wie krass ist denn eigentlich die Natur, dass aus dem Dinosauriern Huhn werden kann? Also von allen Tieren, die es gibt, hätte ich gesagt, ja, gib mir Komodowaran, gib mir Alligator, gib mir Giraffe von mir aus. Aber Huhn? Und Elefanten haben auch nichts mit Dinosauriern zu tun. Null. Niedelpferde haben nichts mit dem Pizzerra-Soph zu tun.
Was ist das eigentlich, diese Mammutnummer? Vor 20 Jahren habe ich schon gelesen, dass Forscher versuchen, das Mammut zurückzubringen. Wo ist mein Mammut? Wo ist dein Mammut? Wo ist dein Hausmammut? So ein kleines Mammutchen. Und am Ende stellt sich heraus, dass das Mammut, Mammut kann ja exakt dasselbe passieren. Man weiss ja nicht, wie zottelig das wirklich war. Am Ende war es ein Elefant mit Pflaumen. Halt einfach so ein leicht behaarter Elefant. Und halt in Ace Age oder so siehst du halt dieses riesige Zottelding, wo du halt einfach, woher weiss man, wie lange die Haare waren. So, aber lässt der Grüger da unten den Motor laufen eigentlich? Das habe ich so auch schon ein paar Mal beobachtet. Sag mal, das war nicht dein Ernst, oder was? Wie lange kann man denn einparken? Oh Gott, mein Gott, jetzt sitzt er zum dritten Mal. Jetzt schrammt er die Sabine da. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Den Corsa, der Sabine schrammt. Warum hat der eigentlich drei Parkplätze bekommen und wir keine einzigen? Wir stehen auf F hinten. Wir stehen auf F. Die stehen hier vorne auf D. Alter, guck dir das mal an, weißt du? Mit seinem Peugeot, mit seinem scheiß Peugeot-Fähre da heim. Ja, aber wir tauschen jetzt mit tauschen jetzt mit dem Grögel, weil der hat ja ein Parkplatz auf C bekommen. Und der kommt nicht so häufig mit dem Auto. Der Grögel kommt ja immer mit dem Hintereingang rein, für den ist C ja in Ordnung, das ist ja das Ding. Lass doch mit dem tauschen, da können wir auf C stehen. Ich habe ja schon mit dem gesprochen, aber für den ist das ja gar nicht so schlecht so, der hat ja da eh keinen Bock drauf. Warum stehen wir da hinten auf D? Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Du hast das verhandelt. So, Entschuldigung. Jetzt, wir mussten kurz. Also, das ist immer wieder schwierig hier. Ihr kennt das. Ihr kennt das ja, ne? Schwierige Sache. Ja, ich finde es lame. Ich find's auch lame und ich hab wenig Hoffnung in das Mammut, weil mittlerweile wird alles entzaubert.
Wer weiss, ob es überhaupt Flugdinosaurier gab, vielleicht hatten die einfach nur irgendwie eine lange Zunge oder was auch immer, keine Ahnung, und die haben das verwechselt, huch, wir dachten, es sei Flügel, nee, es ist einfach eine lange Arme. Die sind einfach Arme, sie sind einfach zu lange Arme. Das, was der T-Rex zu wenig hätte, haben die so hinter sich hergezogen, immer durch den Sand gezogen. Die waren halt einfach noch so Prototypen von Tieren, also die Evolution, als sie angefangen hat, war die Tiere alle Quatsch. Ich muss das schon mal sagen, die waren halt dumm, die waren zu lange Arme, drei Köpfe und irgendwann so, nee, das lassen wir alles, das machen wir anders. Das ist ein bisschen wie, wenn du dir Geschwister anguckst, oft bei Gleichgeschlechtlich kannst du es sehr gut sehen. Das erste ist immer so ein Natur-tried, das zweite ist dann schon ein bisschen besser und das dritte ist dann nochmal in eine andere Richtung all in gegangen.
Aber oft sind die Erstgeborenen, das ist vielleicht super schwierig, was ich jetzt mache, weil es ist alles Scherz, es ist alles Fun in Bits, aber die Erstgeborenen sind immer ein bisschen hässlicher als alles, was danach kommt. Absolut. Das ist wie wenn du irgendwie so ein Rollenspiel spielst, dein erster Charakter, den hast du komplett verskillt, der hat komische Hosen an, der hat eine komische, komische Augen und beim zweiten Mal weißt du, ja, okay, so und so läuft das. Und das dritte ist dann ein Gag. Und das dritte ist dann der Meme-Charakter, wo du sagst, ich spiel jetzt mal einen Gaukler oder so und so, der ist dann halt kompletter Crap. Aber du weißt schon, was du machen willst, also der sieht nicht mehr so versuchsschenehmlich aus wie Erste, Erstgeborene. Ja genau, aber du weißt, was du machen willst, aber es ist auch, du weißt, dass es nicht Meta ist, du weißt, dass es nicht so richtig
funktioniert. Aber hat das mal jemand untersucht?
Stimmt das, was wir gerade erzählen,
oder es ist einfach nur schlecht beobachtet?
Weiß ich nicht. Könnt ihr gerne mal aus
eurer Familie heraus berichten,
ob ihr sagt, wir haben eine jüngere Geschwister,
sind wirklich alle erfolgreich und schön
und ich nicht?
Schreibt mal. Du hast doch zwei Brüder. Wer ist der attraktivere Bruder von den beiden Brüdern? Das ist auch eine doofe Frage, die ich jetzt gestellt habe. Da drehe ich dich schon in so eine Ecke, die du jetzt... Nee, da würde ich... Also es ist natürlich klar, es gibt ja nicht nur Genetik. Es gibt ja natürlich auch, wie man sich dann... Nee, da würde ich schon sagen, der der ... Gute eine ist im Knast, aber es macht ihn auch irgendwie hot.
Ja.
So.
Genau.
Zum Thema Haribo-Maskottchen.
Wir wollten die Petition starten.
Es gibt dieses Haribo-Maskottchen, es gibt zwei.
Es gibt den Goldbären und den kleinen Jungen, den schwarzhaarigen Jungen,
der aber immer nur auftaucht, wenn La Kritze im Spiel ist. Und wir wollten ihn Lars Kritze nennen, stellt sich heraus, er heisst Harry Boy. Harry Boy. Harry Boy. Es gibt ein französisches Spiel. Das ist ein richtiger Harry Boy. Es gibt ein französisches Spiel. Das ist wie Elevator Boy. Harry Boy. Elevator Boy? Wie die Elevator Boys. Boy. Boy. Wie so ein TikTok-Phänomen klingt das, der Harry Boy. Ja, der Harry Boy. Harry Boy. Elevator Boy? Wie die Elevator Boys. Boy. Wie so ein TikTok-Phänomen klingt das. Der Harry Boy. Ja, der Harry Boy. Boy. Boy. Boy ist so ein cooles Wort. Boy. Boy. Boy. Boy. Boy. Gleicher Wollstamm. Okay, und der Harry Boy? Harry Boy und wir haben auf jeden Fall es, wir finden, also Langsam, Flut denn? So, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt gerade. Piratos, ja, die schwarzen Goldmünzen, die ... No body care. Ich schwange hier zwischen, erklär es langsamer, damit es doch irgendwer folgen kann, und mach es schneller, damit wir es hinter uns haben. Piratos, die Goldmünzen aus Lakritze, wo ja nicht der schwarzhaarige Junge drauf war, sondern der Pirat. Wo mir Leute geschrieben haben, Leute, Leute, bitte aufpassen, Piratos sind mit die heftigsten Lakritz-Produkte, die es gibt von Haribo. Fast verboten. Die sind nicht für Kinder, da steht extra drauf, nicht für Kinder, deswegen gibt es extra nicht den Haribo mit Piratenhut. Der nächste, der mir... Nee, hör auf, sag lieber schwarzhaariger Junge, ich finde das irgendwie besser. Ja, der nächste, der mir geschrieben hat, meinte, ja, es gibt auch Packungen von Piratus mit dem Harry Boy, mit dem schwarzhaarigen Jungen drauf und es gibt tatsächlich auch Packungen mit dem schwarzhaarigen Jungen in Piratenhut drauf. Trotzdem, der schwarzhaarige Junge ist auf vielen Produkten, die keine Lakritze haben, auf Piccolo... Picoballa. Picoballa haben wir gesehen, also kompletter Bullshit. Picoballa ist ein Football-Outfit. Wie heißt das Wort? Fussball. Das hat mich irritiert. Blinzel zweimal, wenn ich dir Hilfe. Das hat mich irritiert, weil da ist ja nichts mit Lakritz zu tun. Null, gar nichts. Aber es ist auch nicht Friechbruchgummi so richtig. Ja, doch schon
eher. Nein, aber auf jeden Fall,
ich glaube, wir brauchen früher oder später ein Statement von
Haribo und ich setze gerade einen
Brief auf, der sich gepfeffert hat,
der direkt nach Bonn
geht. Ich werde auch einfach nur, ich werde
oft, ich glaube, es reicht, wenn du auf den
Brief als Adresse Haribo
schreibst, oder? Die Post wird das schon hinkriegen.
Haribo.
Weil jeder weiß ja, wo in Bonn das ist. Und in Bonn werden die auch nicht sagen, habe ich noch nie gehört. Und ganz ehrlich, Brocker ist das so ein Unternehmen, die haben die Strassen nach sich benannt. Es gibt manchmal so Orte wie am Bundestag eins oder sowas. Ich glaube, es ist bei Haribo auch einfach, du schreibst auf Haribo-Strasse eins. Die heissen aber auch so Pico-Balla-Allee.
Pico-Balla-Allee.
Genau, sowas in der Richtung.
Oder Colorado Road.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Ich glaube wirklich, dass die Post auch mehr drauf hat, als man ihr zutraut. Also jetzt mal ein kleiner Shoutout an die Post. Ich glaube, du musst auch teilweise da nicht alles draufschreiben. Ich glaube, wenn du da, ich glaube wirklich, wenn du auf dem Brief, ich probiere das mal aus, ich schreibe auf dem Brief Haribo als Adresse.
Machst du einen Zwickersmiley noch rein oder einfach versuchen mal. Und werf ihn in den Post und guck einfach, ob der ankommt. Ich glaube, der kommt an. Man schätzt das häufig. Was auch spannend ist, der beste Trick immer noch der Welt, wenn du dir das Porto sparen willst, den Porto, wie auch immer. Wenn du das nicht frankieren willst, vertauschst du einfach Absender und Empfängeradresse und schmeißt es ohne Briefmarke rein und dann kriegt der Absender, der unser Empfänger ist, das kostenlos zugestellt, weil es unzustellbar ist. Aber wenn du jetzt den Brief in Köln in den Postkasten wirfst und da steht als Absender Stefan in Hamburg drauf. Du hättest ja in Köln im Urlaub sein können und hast es da eingeworfen, unfrankiert, der kommt dann angeblich zu dir nach Hause. Aber das ist schon ein bisschen gemein. Nee, ist gemein. Ja, aber das ist gemein. Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass du das machen soll. Ich habe nur gesagt, das ist der fantastische, das ist der irreste Loophole. Nee, das ist gemein. Ja. Nee, mach das nicht. Nee, mach das nicht. Vor allem die Briefmarke ist doch cool so. Da hast du eine Briefmarke. Aber das ist so ein Scam, wo man denkt, ja na klar. Aber das ist gemein. Flonti, ne? Nee, ich weiß. Das will ich nicht. Alles gut. Nee, das ist gemein. Nee, ich weiß. Ich will nicht, dass du das... Irgendwie entzauberst du dich gerade auch so ein bisschen. Du bist wegen der Dinosaurier. Man denkt, du bist so ein Saubermann, irgendwie so ein... Natürlich ein herb männlicher Typ, klar. Herber männlicher... Aber trotzdem, wo man einer sage, der auch irgendwie gewisse Tugendhaftigkeit in den Tag legt. Du entzauberst dich gerade. Stefan Tietze entzaubert dich. Ich sage ja nicht, dass ich es mache. Mir gefällt das ja auch nicht. Mir gefällt auch nicht, dass mein Gehirn an diese Orte geht. Ich möchte nur sagen, dass ich das einfach so ein irres Loophole finde. Und man muss natürlich sagen, durch deine Recherche zu How to Sell musstest du dich natürlich auch viel mit Post und Postwegen und illegalen Dienstleistungen auseinandersetzen. Also das ist natürlich, da begebst du dich berufshalber schon mal in sinistrischen Sphären. Bei mir zu Hause kamen ja auch ein paar Drogenpäckchen an. Ich habe ja auch Testkäufe gemacht. Die kamen dann bei mir an. Im Internet? Im Internet habe ich das gekauft. Aber im Dark Web oder auf ähnlichen Seiten wie Shiny Flags? Im Darknet habe ich bestellt und habe Testkäufe getätigt. Die kamen dann bei mir an. Und das war auch immer interessant. Oft waren da Absender drauf, die es nicht gab, weil es einfacher ist, ein Brief, also sicherer ist, einen Brief mit einem Absender, der erfunden ist, einzuwerfen, als keinen Absender drauf zu haben. Da reagiert die Post eher schon mal ein bisschen irritiert, warum da jetzt kein Absender draufsteht. Und die Drogen hast du dann vernichtet und... Ja. Ja. Done. Also wie vernichtet. Kann man... Oh. Alles gut, kann man, weil du laberst ja hier oft auch, was hier passiert ist und so und die meisten Fans, da gibt es jetzt auch so ein paar Dokus darüber, dass sie da Verschwörungen wittern und so und du das vielleicht alles gar nicht erlebt hast und gar nicht, gar nicht das, gar nicht das bist, was du vorgibst zu sein. Ja.uft da nur noch. Der Podcast-Swindler auf Netflix. Ja, ja, der Mutstapler. Podcast-Swindler. Deswegen würde ich mich interessieren, ob man einen Lügendetektor, der macht ja vor allem was mit der Stimme oder nicht. Nur Heartrate? Nur Heartrate? Du hast ja sowas am Finger oder so.
Du hast ein Ding am Finger.
Du meinst, ob du einen Podcast durch einen Lügendetektor jagen kannst?
Ich will einen Podcast langfristig durch einen Lügendetektor geschmeissen.
Und dann soll der mir sagen, übrigens ist schon eine Fehlermeldung am Start,
der Podcast-Lügendetektor soll mir sagen, ob der Podcast gerade lügt oder nicht oder Podcasterin.
Ja.
Fantastisch.
Das finde ich so.
Gute Idee. Ich glaube, man kann da viel an der Stimme machen, aber ich glaube, es ist oft auch Körpersprache oder die Herzrate. Das fehlende Herz. Das fehlende Herz. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Ausschlag hier, Herr Kommissar. Du bedrückst diese Fehlermeldung, die ich neuerdings sehe, weil die Raumaufteilung neu ist, immer weg. Verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Aber die will ja was sagen, diese Fehlermeldung Arbeitst nicht, Stefan. Wir gucken jetzt gar nicht hin. Gucken wir jetzt mal schön weg. Weg. Ja, guck mal schön weg. Nee, aber du bist ansonsten schon ein ehrlicher Typ. Saubermann. Du bist schon ein Saubermann eigentlich. Saubermann. Aber hast du schon mal so richtig das Gesetz gebrochen? Ja, da möchte ich es dir nicht sagen. Zählt es als Geständnis, wenn man das hier sagt? Oder kann man vor Gericht immer noch sagen, das ist Herr Kokolores? It was funny at the time. Du beziehst dich auf den Kokolores-Paragrafen. Also Kokolores ist ja natürlich immer so eine Frage. Wir machen ja einen Kokolores-Podcast. Der Podcast ist ein grosser Kokolores. Das klingt auch wie ein Produkt von Haribo, oder? Hier sind eine Packung Kokolores oder so. Saure Kokolores? Wahrscheinlich, ist das die Adresse? Haribo Kokolores 2. Saure Kokolores 3. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht eigentlich. Am Kokolores 1. Kannst du dich noch erinnern? Ist das ein Berg aus Herr der Ringe? Karadras. Kannst du dich noch erinnern, dass wir kurz davor waren, eine riesige Lieferung Schokoriegel bei Haribo produzieren zu lassen? Während Gute Arbeit Originals hatten wir verschiedene Ideen, wie wir das Projekt teasern und die Idee war, wir haben verschiedene Richtungen, also wir machen einen Horrorfilm-Trailer, einen Morningshow-Trailer, damit die Leute erstmal gar nicht wissen, was es ist. Und wir bringen Süßigkeiten auf den Start, damit man nicht weiß, was am Ende da kommt. Genau, und eine Idee war auch, dass wir einen Schokoriegel namens Gute Arbeit Originals machen und die Idee war Fruchtuchtgummi Kern mit Schokohülle. Und wir waren wirklich mit Haribo im Gespräch, könnt ihr das für uns produzieren? Und interessanterweise haben die gesagt, ja. Und dann haben die gefragt, wie viel braucht ihr denn? Und wir so, ja, so 200 Stück. Und die meinten so, ja, Produktion beginnt bei uns ab 20 Tonnen oder so. Ja, genau, dafür lohnt es uns nicht, die Maschinen anzuschmeissen, haben die gesagt. Jetzt bin ich interessiert. Aber warum haben wir da eigentlich nie weiter... Also da hat uns ein international erfolgreiches Unternehmen gesagt, wir machen euren Riegel. Das ist anscheinend machbar, dass du deinen eigenen, selbst ausgedachten Haribo-Fruchtprodukt einfach machst. Warum bist du so irritiert? Du kannst alles machen. Du kannst auch Waffen herstellen. Du kannst alles machen. Es geht halt nur darum... Ja, aber ich kann auch nicht zu Sony gehen und sagen, mach mir meine eigene Spielekonsole. Doch. Nein. Doch. Also das Ding ist ja, du musst denen ja schon sagen, was für Schokolade, du musst denen schon sagen, wie soll der schmecken, du musst denen die Rezeptur geben. Du kannst ja nicht zu BMW gehen und sagen, mach mir ein Auto mit drei Rädern. Nein, du musst nicht... Dann machen die da... Dann sagen, mach mir tausend Autos mit drei Rädern. Jetzt sei mal nicht so naiv. Ich weiß, mögen wir alle, lieben wir alle an die... Jetzt erkläre mir bitte mal die Welt. Ich brauche wirklich ein bisschen... So, wenn man genug Geld hat, und darüber haben wir jetzt noch nicht gesprochen, kannst du denen natürlich, du musst denen auch alles anliefern. Die haben ja ihre Maschinen. Dann musst du denen theoretisch aber die Spritzform geben, in die dann Schokolade reinkommt und so, die müsste dann extra angefertigt werden, machen die vielleicht sogar für einen, kostet aber alles einen Haufen Geld. Das macht erst Sinn, hat man eine gefrisse Abnahmemenge. Wahrscheinlich hätten wir die auch beliefern müssen mit Zucker, den ganzen Zutaten, die wir brauchen, mit gut, wir brauchen 20 Tonnen Zucker von euch und so, und da müssen wir in Rewe gehen und sagen... Aber warum macht das denn niemand? Also warum macht das denn nicht... Weil es total dusselig ist. Aber wahrscheinlich steht dann da nicht drauf Haribo. Also das ist dann halt unser Ding. Die vermarkten das ja dann auch nicht. Wir haben nur deren Maschinen angezapft. Und da bin ich ja wirklich interessiert, was sind das denn für Maschinen? Haben die eine Schokoladenspritzmaschine, haben die eine Fruchtgummimaschine, wie laufen diese Maschinen ab? Ja, ich dachte immer, ach so, ja, du hast schon recht, ich dachte immer so, jedes Produkt hat seine eigene Maschine, aber wahrscheinlich nicht, die müssen dann wahrscheinlich die Sachen austauschen und dann geht's los, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn. Ja, also wenn ihr in Bonn wohnt. Aber lassen uns da mal ein Preisangebot reinholen oder so. Und dann können wir, wir können ja so ein Crowdfunding machen, dann halt einfach das Podcast-Ufo, den Riegel, und dann machen wir irgendwie Kickstarter oder so. Jeder zahlt fünf Euro, der so einen Riegel haben will, am Ende dann kaufen wir uns von dem Ganzen eine riesige hundert Tonnen. Wir haben hier Platz auf der Brücke, in unserem Büro, wir haben offensichtlich Platz! Und das können wir hier stapelweise Kisten hinstellen mit unserem eigenen Riegel, der dann furchtbar schmeckt. Aber es gibt dann Haribo auch Feedback so, ja, haben wir gelesen, aber das wird nicht gut schmecken. Also die wissen ja auch, was sie tun oder machen die einfach, ja okay, machen wir für euch. Ich würde machen, was sie wollen, wenn die uns abziehen können, die wollen uns auch abziehen, glaube ich. Aber ich finde das immer super, weil ich habe mal, als ich umgezogen bin, wollte ich eine neue Küche haben, ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Geschichte mal hier erzählt habe, und mit so einer Küchenfirma das dann durchgesprochen und so und was ich mir vorstelle und am Ende haben sie mir dieses Angebot vorgelegt für 70.000 Euro. Und dann saß ich da und ich war schon viel zu weit in dem Prozess drin. Ich war einfach zu naiv und dachte, das wird günstiger. Du hast da schon irgendwie Bacon gebraten in der Pfanne. Die haben mir schon so Arbeitsplattenmuster hingelegt und so, mir Wasser angeboten und so. Ich habe schon deren Donuts angerührt und saß dann da am Tisch und bin morgens aus dem Haus wieder hingekommen und so. Die haben schon diese Küche geplant und legen mir dann dieses Angebot vor für 70.000 Euro. Und dann habe ich auch nicht sofort sagen können, weil ich mich verarschen, ich bin 70.000 Euro für die Küche, habe ich auch am Anfang auch nicht gesagt, dass ich nicht so viel Bezieher habe. Und so, und dann war ich aber noch, konnte ich nicht alles sofort sagen, sondern saß da noch ein bisschen da und habe mir noch mal, habe es mal so planspielmäßig so durchgespielt, habe auch noch so ein paar Rückfragen gestellt und ach, und wenn ich auf diese Arbeitsplatte, ah dann wären wir bei 84.000, ja gut, aber die ist natürlich auch schön. Also man ist ein bisschen, ich habe es mal ein bisschen mitgespielt. Reine Fantasiewelt ab dem Zeitpunkt, ja. Ich hab mal kurz Fantasielarb gespielt, ein bisschen. Und ehrlich gesagt, fände ich das mal geil, auch mal zu machen mit Dingen, die noch utopischer sind. Warum nicht mal eine Yacht angucken? Genau, ja. Weil ich denke mir, wenn du... Aber dann so super detailliert so, ja, der Schriftzug in Rot wäre schon schön draußen, aber in Blau ein bisschen teurer, weil Rot ist natürlich die Standardvariante. Wie teurer wäre das denn dann? Naja, also wir würden dann natürlich von 9,8 Millionen auf 9,8 Millionen 4.000 gehen. Das ist dann natürlich... Ja, aber das ist natürlich auch... Dafür ist die Farbe jetzt mal mit Levis Farbe. Ja, die ist schön und das können Sie natürlich auch immer noch... Also die Yacht wird ja erstmal produziert und Sie können im Nachhinein das natürlich noch entscheiden. Ich will diese Gespräche haben, weil auch einmal mal durchzuspielen, was es jetzt kosten würde, das Podcast-Ufo-Riegel rauszubringen. Lass uns noch mal eine Anfrage... Ich habe den Brief noch nicht losgeschickt. Lass uns mal 50% Beschwerde, 50% Angebot, 50% hey Leute, kriegt mal euren scheiss schwarzenhaarigen Jungen unter Kontrolle. Andersrum, andersrum. Erst Angebot, damit die das entspannt lesen und dann das konstruktiv ausdrückte Feedback, was das fucking Problem mit dem schwarzenhaarigen Jungen ist. Okay. Ich überlege es mir noch, ob ich es nicht anders... Okay, klar. Weil du musst erst mal auf den Tisch schauen. Gut, ich verstehe schon. Und so Leute so mit mir nicht, ich lasse mich nicht verarschen und dann kommt das Geschäft. Erst mal sagen, wir wissen, wovon wir reden. Genau. Wir kommen hier nicht ohne Expertise rein. Aber jetzt mal, sorry, ich ratter das gerade beim Kopf durch, weil es gibt seit Jahrzehnten ein Produkt, das ich liebe und im Herzen trage, das es nicht mehr gibt. Ich rede von den Trolley Cheesecakes. Es gibt ja Trolley, da kennt ihr wahrscheinlich, da gibt es den Fruchtgummi Burger, da gibt es den Fruchtgummi Pizza und es gab auch mal die Fruchtgummitorte Trolley Cheesecakes. Ekligen Trolli-Geschmack. Super ultrasüss, künstlich, aber das Geile an den Trolli-Cheesecakes waren, die hatten, das waren so Tortenstückchen in drei verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen mit so einem Knusperboden, mürbeteigem Boden, sollte da imitiert werden. Und die konnte man immer kaufen in so einer Torte. Also die konntest du in einer Tüte kaufen oder sechs Stücke davon waren eine Torte und die konntest du so in so einer Packung kaufen, so wie du den Burger auch kaufen kannst. Oder die Pizza in der Pizzapackung, konntest du auch diesen Burger kaufen. Und die werden nicht mehr hergestellt. Und die waren köstlich. Es muss doch jetzt möglich sein, wenn ich Trolli einfach mal irgendwie jetzt die besagten 70.000 Euro gebe, macht mir mal noch ein paar Tonnen davon. So, und jetzt habe ich eine andere Idee. Und jetzt spielen wir nämlich, und da müssen wir aufpassen, dass wir nicht irgendwie so Herr der Ringe Hobbits zwischen den grossen Elefanten irgendwie so in die Schussbahn geraten von diesen beiden Giganten.
Aber wir können ja auch Haribo und Trolli gegeneinander ausspielen.
Ja, weiter, weiter.
Gehen wir mal bitte näher drauf ein.
Was mir jetzt gefällt ist, wir sagen Haribo, wir würden es sonst mit Trolli machen und wir sagen Trolli, wir würden es sonst mit Haribo machen.
Ja.
Und dann mal gucken, was dann so passiert. Vielleicht führen wir noch einen dritten im Spiel. Ja, Hitchler vielleicht. Nee, das möchte ich nicht. Aber die haben gerade die sauren Krakenarme rausgebracht, die übernehmen gerade den Markt, die haben richtig gute Ideen gerade, muss man echt sagen. Hitchis. Hitchis natürlich immer gern, auch die sauren? Ey, die haben mir so oft den Mund zerfetzt, einfach wirklich. Die schmecken so geil, weil du dein eigenes Blut mitschmeckst. Diese sauren Hitchis, die einfach, wie sie einfach so ein Stück Schmirgelpapier in deinem Mund sind und einfach da wüten. Ja, ja, du merkst auch, wie oben der Gaumen das Dach des Mundes ein bisschen aufgerissen ist. Ja, wie so eine Ölbohrmaschine, die sich einfach reinbohrt, einfach in deinen Gaumen und irgendwo im Kopf ist. Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn ich im Gehirn drei saure Hitchis habe, die sich da irgendwie hochgebohrt haben und da einfach seitdem da sind. Übrigens vielen Dank an die vielen Nachfragen, weil ich letzte Woche nicht erwähnt habe, wie mein Bluttest ausgegangen ist. Vor zwei Wochen hatte ich kein Blut mehr im Körper, da wurde mir Blut abgenommen und dann hat niemand geschrieben.
Niemand hat gefragt, weil ich letzte Woche habe vergessen zu erzählen, dass es mir gut geht.
Sind die diskret? Wir haben sehr diskrete Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Nein, es wurden Comics gemalt über unsere lustigen Dialoge. Es gibt lustige Re-Enactments, Schulstücke von den lustigen Bits, die wir abgeführt haben.
Niemand hat mich gefragt und das zeigt mir...
Das ist aber echt Schwachleute.
Das ist Schwachleute.
Man ist in einer Neidgesellschaft. Moment, weil die dein Blutwein haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, ich wollte einen anderen Punkt aufmachen, aber man gönnt mir meine Gesundheit glaube ich nicht. Okay, ist eine Theorie. Dann klär uns doch mal auf, dann frage ich jetzt mal nach. Nö, ist alles gut. Stefan, wie lief denn eigentlich dein Bluttest? Wie läuft es mit deinem Tumor? Alles gut, nicht aktiv. Wachstumshormon im normalen Umfang. Alles super, alles lief gut. Vielen Dank der vielen Nachfragen. Ja, dann ist doch nichts, dann ist doch okay. Ja, ich mache ja nur. Dann macht doch hier kein Rambazamba. Ich mache hier Rambazamba, weil ich möchte wissen, aber das ist doch, hätte auch mal nach hinten losgehen können jetzt. Stefan, wir brauchen dich noch, wir brauchen dein Anti-Aids-Blut. Jetzt haben sie mir ja schon aus meinen Adern gezogen. Ich hänge wie in der Matrix, hänge ich da oben dran und dann ziehen sie mir mein Blut, mein Anti-Aids-Blut raus. Ziehen sie mir alles raus. Du darfst nicht sterben, du darfst nicht sterben. Du darfst jetzt nicht irgendwie wilde Bungee-Jumping-Sachen machen oder so.
Aber ich will auch nicht mein Blut abgeben, weil dann kann ich sterben. Weißt du, noch brauchen sie mich. Ja, ich habe letztens tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich Bungee-Jumpen gehen will, weil ich habe mir halt mal wieder die Frage gestellt, wer ist der Chef, Körper oder Geist? Und eigentlich muss die Antwort lauten, Gehirn, weil wenn du da oben an einer Klippe stehst, dein ganzer Körper sagt, bau keinen Scheiss jetzt. Du hast eine körperliche Reaktion darauf, dass du jetzt nicht runterspringst. Ja, verstehe ich nicht, weil der Körper hat sich auch da oben hingebracht. Nee, das Gehirn hat sich da hingebracht. Warum tickt der Körper erst so spät? Allein das die Tatsache, dass Leute es geschafft haben, auf einer riesigen Klippe zu stehen, mit Bungee-Jumping-Gummiseilen und dann runtergesprungen sind, wo der Körper, der checkt das ja nicht, also dein Höhenangstinstinkt checkt das ja nicht, dass du jetzt ein Gummiband hast oder so. Allein, dass der Mensch das schafft, in einer so offensichtlich tödlichen Situation auch noch runterzuspringen, weil das Gehirn denkt, ja, das ist ein Kautschukmaterial, das würde mich schon halten, das passt schon, der Typ ist ein Profi. Also da denke ich mir schon, das ist schon beeindruckend. Und ich glaube nicht, ich weiss nicht, ob ich es schaffen würde, da runter zu springen, aber es wäre ein Triumph des freien Willens, so gegen den Körper, der einfach mit allen Fasern sagt, sei hier nicht, hier ist gefährlich, Höhenangst, trotzdem geschafft man es runter zu springen. Das ist doch schon beeindruckend. Lass uns aber eine Folge machen und am Ende der Folge springen wir und die Folge wird akustisch ähnlich schlimm wie diese hier, weil wir halt in einem Flugzeug stehen, wo die ganze Zeit macht und dann... Nee, nicht Flugzeug. Ach so. Du willst Bungee springen aus einem Flugzeug? Sorry, ich war gerade bei Fallschirmspringen. Ich meine, können wir auch. Wir können eine Kombination machen. Wir können entweder auch von einer Brücke Fallschirmspringen oder aus einem Helikopter Bungee springen. Ich will aus einem Helikopter Bungee springen. Nee, das will ich nicht. Dann hätte ich Angst, dass ich wie so eine Abrissbirne gehe in so eine Hausdotz oder so. Das ist eh meine Angst beim bungee springen.
Da hätte ich keine Angst. Meine Angst ist, dass ich mich nicht gedreht bekomme und dann mit den Füssen nach unten und dann, wenn das Seil dann greift, dass ich so ganz schnell rumschlag und dann mein Genick bricht oder so. Das ist meine grösste Angst. Meine grösste Eingang ist, dass ich, weil es, habe ich, meine ich, gab es noch mal diese tragische Geschichte am Dortmunder Fernsehturm, der Florian, wo jemand gesprungen ist und dann gegen den Turm geklatscht ist.
Okay, ja, das ist freierlich.
Und dann denke ich mir, darauf seid ihr nicht gekommen, dass das eine Alternative ist, dass meine erste Urangst ist, doch zu nah an diesem Turm in den Langen zu springen und dann durch diesen Aufprall gegen den Turm gedrückt zu werden. Das ist das Schlimmste. Warum seid ihr doch nicht gekommen? Und dafür habe ich immer Angst, dass das passieren kann. Mir ist der Ertrag nicht groß genug. Da sind schon zu viele dumme Sachen passiert. Es ist auch so dumm, es ist auch so offensichtlich gefährlich. Ich habe ja mal zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwo mitspielst in einem Film oder einer Serie und du hast mehrere Drehtage. Relatable, relatable, mehr, mehr, mehr von so einem Relatable. Du hast mehrere Drehtage. Deswegen hören Leute um. Das ist bestimmt in vielen anderen Sachen auch so, aber wenn du da anfängst, dann unterschreibst du tatsächlich einen Vertrag, in dem steht, ab dem ersten Drehtag darfst du dich nicht mehr unnötig in Gefahr begeben. Wird denn spezifiziert, was unnötige Gefahren sind? Da steht zum Beispiel drauf Extremsportarten, Bungee springen. Weil wenn du angedreht bist, sprich wenn die einen Drehtag mit dir hatten, dann wenn du jetzt stirbst, Kostenapparat. Genau, wenn du stirbst, müssen sie jemanden neu casten und den ersten Drehtag komplett wiederholen, was teuer ist. Das heißt, du verpflichtest dich, dich nicht in Gefahr zu begeben, wo du dir denkst, wenn das schon so bürokratisch da drinsteht, kein Bungee springen, dann warum macht es überhaupt irgendjemand irgendwann mal irgendwann? Weil du einfach denkst, das ist also offensichtlich tödlich, gefährlich. Ich bin natürlich trotzdem auf das Skatepark gegangen, mich hält niemand auf, Rock'n'Roll, Baby. Ja, bist trotzdem immer kurz joggen gegangen, crazy guy. Was mir gefällt, wenn ihr in so Bürokontexten seid, sagt man häufiger einfach, ja, aber der Kostenapparat. Ja, der Kostenapparat. Da denkt ihr ein ganzer Kostenapparat dran. Das gefällt mir auch. Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Oder ja, der Rattenschwanz. Ihr werdet viel Nicken ernten. Ja. Ein paar Fragende Blicke auch, aber viel Nicken. Generatisches Wort App Apparat ist einfach toll. Ja, ich glaube, weil 80 Prozent Zonen raus am Anfang eines Meetings sind raus. Wenn dann jemand sagt Kostenapparat, da ist schon so ein Nicken vorprogrammieren. Der ganze Versorgungsapparat. Und da müssen wir überlegen mit dem ganzen Parkapparat, wohin denn die ganzen Autoparat. Nicht Apparello sagen. Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Nicht, ja, der ganze Kosten-Aparillo. Nee, das nicht. Ihr fliegt sofort aus. Das nicht, da fliegt man sofort aus. Da wird erstmal sofort das Donutkauen beendet und man guckt dich böse an. Aparillo? Klingt nicht sehr... Nee, klingt nicht gut. Gut. Nee, ich finde es total durslich, sich in solche Gefahrhandsituation zu bringen. Aber spannende Frage, die du aufgebracht hast. Das Gehirn ist ja eigentlich nur darauf aus, es zu überleben. Naja, sich fortzupflanzen und zu überleben, sind ja schon irgendwie Urinstinkte. Fortpflanzen, nicht sterben, Snacken. Sprinkles, die Sachen. Und dann verstehe ich nicht, warum ist selbst man überhaupt eine Option für Gehirne. Warum sind selbstvernichtende Dinge, auch wie Rauchen und so, denn überhaupt …
Ja gut, Rauchen ist ja super abstrakt, da musst du ja erstmal schon lange checken. Geht so, ehrlich gesagt. Naja, aber das Gehirn … Es gab eine lange Zeit, da haben Ärzte Rauchen als Gesundheitsförderung verschrieben. Also dass dann das Gehirn nochmal checkt, ach so, ne, Moment mal, in der aktuellen Studie. Also das kann ich schon verstehen, dass das Gehirn bei Rauchen nicht versteht. Dass du für eine brennendeanz in dich in deine Lunge einheilierst, in deinem Körper, ist schon fucking offensichtlich eine schlechte Idee. Das sei jemals eine Art, diese Zeit, die kann ich auch nicht ernst nehmen, das ist wie die Zeit jetzt, wo die große Hühner auf einer losgegangen sind, ähnlich lame, die nicht mehr geraucht haben. Ja, ähnlich lame, dass da Ärzte irgendwann mal dachten, dass es eine gute Idee ist, brennende Substanzen in sich hineinzusaugen. Ja, vielleicht war Rauch nicht immer so schädlich. Vielleicht dachte man, früher Rauch ist eine gute Sache, Feuer ist eine gute Sache. Vielleicht Rauch ist besser als der durchschnittliche Raum. Ich meine, Leute zünden sich eine Kerze in ihrer Wohnung an. Da kannst du auch sagen, das ist so offensichtlich gefährlich. Geht so. Ja, meinst du? Nein, Kerzen sind nicht so gefährlich. Es ist schon schwierig, was das Gehirn als gefährlich versteht und was nicht. Wenn du da irgendwie mit 200 kmh über die Autobahn ballerst, das Gehirn ist dem scheißegal, weil das halt wahrscheinlich auch nicht darauf ausgelegt ist, das als Gefahrensituation zu verstehen und es sich auch nicht so anfühlt, als sei es gefährlich. Aber so eine kleine Spinne, wo du genau weißt, ja, ich kenne mich aus, ich habe was ist was spinnen gelesen, die kann nichts, ich bin stärker als die Spinne, da sagt das Gehirn plötzlich, uh, Vorsicht, gefährlich. Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Wann geht das eigentlich mal weg? Also Spinnen sind doch seit Jahrhunderten keine echte Gefahr mehr für den Menschen in Europa oder so. Also jetzt, wo Autobahnen seit einigen Jahrzehnten grosse Gefahren sind für Menschen. Wie träge kann denn sowas wie Spinnenangst sein, dass das irgendwann mal abgelegt wird? Weil ich meine, wenn du sagst jetzt Evolution, es wird mal irgendein Mensch geboren, der hat keine Angst vor Spinnen und der stirbt halt auch nicht, weil Spinnen keine Gefahr sind, dann gibt er das weiter an alle anderen und irgendwann müssen ja eigentlich alle keine Angst mehr vor Spinnen haben, weil es kein Selektionsfaktor mehr ist. Wir haben alle das neue Update nicht untergeladen. Niemand hat das Update untergeladen. Das neue engste Update. Ey, seit 50 Jahren klicken wir immer das Update weg, wo man auch sagt, Höhenangst safe ist ein Dauerbrenner, ist ein Klassiker, lasst es herbeibehalten. Aber die Angst vor dunklen Höhlen, die man noch in uns vorherrscht, können wir mal ad acta legen. Angst vor Dunkelheit kann raus, debuggen. Ad acta, das können wir mal ad acta legen. Dunkelheit kann debakt werden, Spinnen, Schlangen, das kann alles weg und dafür bräuchten wir vielleicht neue Ängste. Genau, Rasen brauchen wir, Bungee-Jumping, solche Sachen sind natürlich. Höhenangst immer noch gut, immer noch wichtig. Immer noch gut, immer noch wichtig. Feuer, Rauch, sowas klar, das ist wichtig, das ist glaube ich auch noch nicht so richtig drin im Menschen, weil Feuer noch zu jung ist vielleicht. Vielleicht ist das auch noch ein Faktor. Na ja, das muss ich erinnern, Rauchen, also solche Sachen. Und Zucker wäre halt auch gut, aber langfristig. Zucker wäre super, zumindest im geringen Maße, wenn man so eine Uhr angstvoll entwickelt. Und dann halt. Und halt Haushalt, ich glaube die meinsten Tode im Haushalt. Genau. So eine Badewanne, da müssen alle Alarmglocken angehen. Eine furchtbare Angst vorm Haushalt. So eine nasse Badewanne, aus der sich so ein fetter Körper versucht, rauszubuchten, da müssen alle Alarmglocken angehen. Ja, ich finde gut, wenn wir alle nach einem neuen Update wahnsinnige Angst anschauen. Alle Menschen stehen draußen, vor ihren Häusern und alles ist los. Hast du auch einen neuen Update drunter gehalten? Ja, klar. Ich kann mir die Leiter nicht mehr angucken, ich kann mir diese Kabel, die da überall offen rumliegen, nicht mehr angucken. Ich habe ein Gasherd, ich gehe nicht mehr nach oben. Nee, weiss nicht mehr. Das war's. Ja, vielleicht ist es nicht schlecht. Na mal gucken, also versuch das mal. Versuch das mal zu Hause. Zum Beispiel wie Stefan, ich sage immer, du sollst nicht mehr vonpflanzen, weil du dein Superblut mit Anti-Aids-Immunen hast. Ja, und bin jetzt auch schon dabei. Also ich habe schon vollgepflanzt? Ja, häufig. Heute schon? Heute schon dreimal. Perfekt, wunderbar. Dann macht das weiter. Und falls ihr keine Angst verspitten habt, bitte auch intensiv fortpflanzen. Danke, damit wir das endlich mal rauskriegen. Lade das neue Update runter. Das mit Haribo ist nicht in eurer Niedervorlage, das werden wir übernehmen. Genau, das machen wir alles. Ihr schaut am besten einfach nochmal drüber über die Dinosituation, ob da vielleicht ein paar coole Alternativen herrschen, weil ich habe das Gefühl, wir müssen uns entfernen von den Dinosauriern und ansonsten viele Entschuldigungen, warum ihr euch nicht nach Stefan Tietz das Gesundheit erkundigt habt, das ist euer Ding. Und dann würde ich sagen, treffen wir uns einfach eine Woche nochmal. Ja, wir würden einfach eine Woche nochmal treffen und wie ein langes Telefonat, wo man viel Unsinn erzählt hat.
Und eigentlich wollte man nur sagen, dass wir sich in der nächsten Woche nochmal treffen können.
Genau, schaut einfach nochmal drüber, lasst es nochmal durch den Kopf gehen, geht nochmal schwanger damit und dann sehen wir uns in der Woche.
Ja, geht nochmal schwanger damit und dann müssen wir auch nochmal den Kostenapparat im Blick behalten.
Alles klar.
Bis nächste Woche.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, haben wir es soweit und bis dann macht es gut.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben noch letzter Punkt, das noch abheben und ansonsten haben wir es für heute.
Gut, dann machen wir das auch.
Alles klar, heben wir jetzt ab. Alles da, ciao, wieder an.